[Applause]
okay I can do this and I've ever heard
this and shower so okay unfortunately a
lot of the people I would like to thank
cannot be here but first of all I would
like to thanks the Academy and for
creating this platform for us and big
kiss to Sean and Hector and all the crew
member for this amazing week I would
like to thank all the professor in my
school masha rock my program director
couldn't do this without her my father
my husband and my mother particularly
because she went through all the
melodramatic process of making the film
with me and I could not put this off
without her and be a mom myself seeing
my three-month-old daughter being born
into this world I just feel more urged
to tell good story story don't people
don't really know about because there is
so important and they're hidden
somewhere in the world and they're
waiting for reporters filmmakers told us
out there to discover them and I think
oh my god I'm sorry well just the whole
process is so excruciating but it's so
exciting
[Laughter]
with everything going on in my country
and everything going on here the with
the First Amendment under the threat of
being Endicott I just still like our our
young filmmakers were out there we
should not feel intimidated to speak up
because speaking up is to start up a
change and so just be courageous
[Applause]
be courageous and know that your courage
will be somehow rewarded thanks again
for studio sky thank you guys who gets
amazing
[Applause]